Oh
my parents upon leaving they lost their
restaurant that was their livelihood I
saw my father cry because for 20 years
he worked so hard it just took
everything out of them
they told us um you could have one
suitcase we first went to what was
called an assembly center there was four
of us and in this one horses stall this
is our family number that we are
assigned to we have to keep it on our
clothing we had to wear this word where
we went especially when we are assigned
to different places
we got on the train and they had it all
the blinds closed we couldn't open it up
and we ended up in Utah and they
assigned us barracks there were these
guard towers where sentries were
stationed with their firearms my brother
was in the army he was fighting over
there in Italy in southern France and
his in his mother and father and his
younger son is in a camp
so when I got into high school I felt
very strongly of assimilation and so I
joined the junior statements Club the
German Club the high school band and the
acapella choir I did feel I had to
approve by Americanist
I wanted to just blend into the woodwork
and not make any waves or anything when
the Korean War started in 1950 I
enlisted in the US Army and served my
three years to prove my loyalty I don't
think I ever had felt that I should
prove my American feelings of loyalty I
was born an American and I was
everything that I read and studied and
learned was that I was an American
well right now they're talking about
Muslims they're not they don't want
Muslim to come in you know but I don't
think that's right what's happening to
the Muslims right now is it's really
close to the hearts of the Japanese
Americans because it happened to us
especially during a crisis people forget
the Constitution and what it guarantees
for everyone and so we have to be on
guard constantly otherwise some of these
people will take over and make it
difficult for certain people